let's go to rebecca in cleveland ohio
good morning rebecca how in the world
are you
i'm doing very well dr john thank you so
much for taking my call
oh the pleasure is 1 000 mind it's so
great to talk to you how in the world
can i help
well i've got a marriage question and
which is paralyzing me
uh oh okay let's bring it on yeah a
quick background is i was married 30
years
my husband left me for someone else um
two years later i met a man that i
thought was a perfect partner we ended
up getting married
the first year um it was a disaster it
was truly the worst year of my life
and i left he's a controlling narcissist
so we divorced but since the divorce we
keep getting back together this has been
on and off for two years now
um i take marriage and my vows very
seriously
sometimes to my own detriment and so i'm
really struggling with this
and my question is how do i make a
decision about whether or not this
marriage could be saved or if it even
should be saved
that's a great question so walk me back
to
your parents okay what was your
childhood like
um only child uh overall good
relationship with my
parents very close to my dad he was a
good guy
he was a great guy your mom was awesome
she was awesome um a lot of uh she was
an alcoholic
so i grew up in alcoholic homes so that
created some problems but
later on in life she was sober and we
ended up being best friends when she
passed away
so that's cool what a cool redemption
story
so then take me to your first divorce
you're married 30 years you'll have kids
together
yep three kids so you build a a world
and then one day you come home tell me
about what happens there
um well it is a long story but um due to
a lot of travel
this person got involved in a lot of
infidelity in another country
so i want to back that out because the
way you said that is you blame the
the travel for the infidelity so this
this your your first husband traveled a
lot
and while he was traveling he chose to
violate your marriage covenant right
right gotcha
okay towards the end uh when it all came
out we agreed to reconcile
and i actually moved to the foreign
country to be with him to start over
forgave him and uh about two and a half
weeks into that
he said he changed his mind and sent me
packing
huh yeah um that that was more
devastating
than even finding out about the
infidelity because we were i thought we
were all set to
you know move on to a second chapter of
our lives
had he cheated on you throughout this
30-year marriage is that something
happened there at the end did y'all just
grow apart over time
or is it something woven through the dna
of your relationship
um there were a lot of reasons
a lot of dynamics as far as how
he was as a father to one of our
children
um that created a lot of rift and we
were actually really good partners good
teammates
and when we changed our roles within the
marriage where
i gave up my career stayed home
homeschooled
and then he became the breadwinner
because i used to make more
um our roles change instead of so
instead of being teams and
partners doing everything together now
it was very much
he was working and i was the home person
taking care of all of that
and i think that contributed to this
okay and so fast forward now you are how
long were you were you between marriages
uh let's see four years
four years okay did you did you date
during that time
were you celibate during that time was
it just a season of loneliness and
searching and trying to figure out who
in the world you were
no i had been dating um i had wanted to
be in a relationship with someone and
actually i got to the point where i was
pretty comfortable on my own
being very independent and feeling good
but this person
just seemed like this was the one
yeah you used a word that that for
anybody who
works in in mental health counseling or
coaching is a
giant like pulsing red neon sign of
danger danger which is
he was perfect what what made him
perfect
um that we could spend hours and hours
talking um he
was very active in his church
we seem to have similar values in that
regard
worked well together we ran some
ministry things at church together while
we were dating
uh he was a great parent so he kind of
filled that void that the other
spouse did not um we all romantically
involved i mean was he
was he a good kisser
okay okay okay
so all of these other things were good
right
so all of these other things seem to
check
loneliness boxes right um
void and affirmation boxes right
right he thought he thought it was
beautiful and complimented me and
you know thought it was the greatest
thing since sliced bread so and so then
you
you find perfection the cue the disney
music
and you run off and get married
and then what happens um
kind of right from the beginning there's
also alcoholism involved okay um
right from the beginning the focus was
on
more drinking than i ever realized but
then
also was it always there and you were
just excited about the relationship and
you
chose not to see it ordered i chose i
chose to
yeah i chose to ignore a lot of it um
but it definitely once we were actually
living together 24 hours a day i saw how
much worse it was
gotcha okay and i thought and um
so he ends up cheating on you he ends up
beginning to slowly almost like the blob
movie
encompass and control your life is that
right
yes um so the idea at least especially
from his perspective was we're equal
partners
um everything has to be 50 50
and uh we absolutely don't try to change
each other
um so i had a little bit of a hard time
with that because
i had come from a previous marriage
where we were
very equal partners and everything very
much a team
um and so very quickly within the first
few days
weeks there was just this feeling of
you know if i wanted to do something
basically he had the veto power because
unless we agreed
both of us a hundred percent all he had
to do was say no to everything
i'd like to buy you know a towel to hang
in the kitchen
well i don't want to chase clothes
okay yeah so
what is it about this relationship how
old are you
uh 58 next week 58.
so what is it about this relationship
that you think is worth salvaging
besides the besides the vowel right you
you made a vowel
what what the what is there to hold on
to
well the vowel is the big one um the
probably the
secondary would be there's always that
sliver of hope of could it be better
maybe maybe he's open
to doing this better changing behavior
so i wanna i wanna i wanna step back 30
000 feet
and paint a full picture of rebecca okay
as the daughter of an alcoholic mom
you have been in a peacekeeping role
you have been in a partner management
role
since you set foot on earth
right you had an extraordinary father
who helped mitigate some of that
and what a blessing that was and
probably still is
right that's probably one of the main
reasons you're able to be a great mom
and we're even having this conversation
right now
um but i want you to
watch the the step back and look at the
relational dynamics that have played out
through your life which is somebody
does something they withhold from you or
they
traumatize you right they go to another
country they cheat on you they violate
they kind of rub
your nose in your vows and then they
invite you out there to
to to start over and then they rub your
nose in that decision again
and you're left trying to figure out
what you did right
and then you begin to recreate another
life again you meet the quote-unquote
perfect guy
you start down this road again and you
are
you find yourself once again asking
what do i need to do in this situation
and so i want
as a peacekeeper that's the way you're
wired i want you to
let go of the fantasy he's not going to
change he's not
and i understand the economics of being
a 58 year old woman i don't understand
them right i'm not a 58 year old woman
but i understand there is
something to be said for
just walking out the door my rent might
be hard
right eating might be hard so i don't
know your economic standing so i'm gonna
put that aside over there
and know that that's a powerful thing
for many women um
i also know that the the devastating
thought of 30 more years by yourself
and that's a withering scary proposition
right
yes it is i want to offer you a third
option which is
you are worthy of being loved you're
worthy of
somebody telling you the freaking truth
you're worthy of not being
cheated on you're worthy of buying your
own
freaking towels in your living room in
your kitchen
okay and since you were four
your worthiness has been based on making
sure the people around you are doing
okay and that they're happy and
golden and joyful and fill in the blank
and you might have got a taste of that
in between the two
husbands we'll call them butt crack one
and butt crack two
you got you probably had some peace
there but you're also lonely right
um and here you are with yet another
decision
so i can't tell you whether to leave him
i can't tell you whether to divorce him
i can't tell you what tomorrow's going
to look like for you i can tell you this
he's not going to change he's going to
be the way he's going to be
and i can tell you that you're going to
have to make a decision between
loneliness
you're going to have to make a decision
between moving around your kids
and making them and their grant and your
grandkids your new world
or you're 58 years old i can tell on the
phone that you're fun to hang out with
i can tell on the phone that you care
about other people
you were willing to pack up and move
across the world for some knucklehead
so i know you're kind of a person who's
loyal
lovely fun there is some dude out there
who would love to have you by his side
who's going to treat you with respect
he's going to treat you with dignity
but here's the challenge until you stop
replaying this cycle you're going to
continue to attract
people that bring chaos into the world
that need your peacekeeping for them to
get to the next day
and so i'm gonna strongly recommend you
step back
and you may have been to counseling
before you may have sat with a
professional before
but i want you to go sit with somebody
who's gonna walk you back to day one and
talk about the trauma you endured
as the daughter of an alcoholic mom as
somebody who
was able to reconnect that relationship
later on in life and you probably had to
do some peacekeeping there probably some
shoving down and some
denial and some hey it's all okay that
was the past was just the past so that
you could
um have this new relationship before
your mom passed away
and i want you to work really hard to
get to a place
where you can look in the mirror and
know that guy
totally uh your first husband totally
left you in the dirt
this second guy was not what he what you
thought um
and that brings me to this this this
big picture um that folks often
deal with when they've been cheated on
when they're working through divorce
when they're working through oh my gosh
i'm in relationship number two
number three and that's falling apart is
you stop to lose
or you start to lose trust in you right
and that can be the most
devastating thing because you thought
you were right you thought he was
perfect you thought you'd learned all
your lessons the first time after
30 years three decades and here you are
again
you thought you knew what was next you
thought you knew what you wanted you
thought you knew this guy and oh my gosh
i don't trust myself anymore
and until you can learn to hear your
heart
and listen to it and then follow that as
opposed to
trying to make everybody else well
you're going to continue to cycle and
cycle and cycle so
man i'm going to tell you to let go of
the fantasy i'm so grateful for the call
rebecca
um and we'll be thinking about you
moving forward
everybody listening i want you to hear
me and on the
the tubes that i'm looking at the
youtubes
they told me i can't say the tubes
anymore people on the youtube channel
you are worthy of being loved you're
worthy of not being cheated on
you are worthy of forgiveness you're
worthy of
a good night's sleep